ladies and gentlemen today is an
interesting object lesson and how
easy it is to fake social proof scam
people and projected image of success
all the while the reality is completely
different you're almost like
thanos you just reality is whatever you
want it to be right
today we're looking at a wannabe bernie
madoff a mr
dr terence cash now first of all
what a name how do these people come up
with it derek moneyberg
wesley billion dollar virgin dan the
trillion dollar man pena
and dr terence cash they all go in the
pantheon of great
business coach wealth coach financial
coach
names they're all gonna help you and
look let's let's see what he's doing
before we get into how it all fell apart
you know all the crazy stuff
now going on in the press let's get into
who this guy was like let's say you
didn't
you know you're looking at him a few
months ago what do you see before
coffeezilla makes a video about him
before all this stuff happens
right before it all comes crumbling down
this is basically what you get on his
page it
just projects success right he's uh he's
on a magazine it looks like
right over here and um you know it's
like
transforming your wealth and he's a
wealth coach but his name is doctor oh
that kind of sounds credible right
he's got a little video for us let's see
that everyday people struggle but they
have no plans they don't know
the money rules used by the wealthy oh
but lucky for
you dr terence cash is willing to help
you out out of the kindness of his heart
i'm not hiking through the himalayas
without a guy
i'm simply not doing it if you want to
do it
send me some peaches i guess he's saying
you need a coach or something like that
okay
whatever he's got a wealth creation
course you know this kind of thing
and most importantly something i want to
draw your attention to
he's got the strategic diversified
investment
chairman's fund okay provides you with
passive income
later on uh he would say that this is 12
percent
a year guaranteed that's why he's a want
to be made off because that's what
mate bernie madoff was famous for
offering somewhat reasonable returns
that were just high
like 10 a year it's not too much but it
was consistent right and so that's what
madoff did
it's exactly what this guy did too
but the big takeaway here is that dr
cash
okay had every trapping of success
he was going to events he even raised
four million dollars for his
chairman's fund right where he's
supposedly taking on investors and
paying them out 12
everything seems to be going great in
fact he's got a whole sob story about
how he used to be broke but now he's
rich thanks to uh the
the rich people who shared their secrets
with them that he's willing to share
with you now for a fee 16 years later
that once failing business was now
producing over 30 million dollars
in annual revenues you heard it right
guys dr terence cash has a 30 million
dollar a year business
ultimately after considering a
nine-figure ipo
he enjoyed a private sale of the
business for eight figures
so he's he's super wealthy all this
stuff you get the idea so
why do i hear sirens it's pretty simple
because
everything you just heard is all
a fabrication see all his you know
chairman's fund all that stuff
it's all a gigantic fraud in fact
dr cash was just arrested for securities
fraud
from all his investors so let's let's
take a peek
inside uh this complaint letter from the
sec and doj
it gets spicy now the first thing to
know is that dr cash
shockingly is not his real name his real
name
is terence chalk which i'll admit is a
little less inspired than dr
terence cash but the reason that he
changed his name is very interesting
you'll be interested to know
see terence chalk he's a convicted felon
you'd never know that by searching dr
terence cash it doesn't
doesn't come up that's why he changed
his name
is so that he wouldn't come up that he's
a convicted felon why is he convicted
felon
well back in the 2000s terence was
arrested for identity theft and
conspiring to make false statements
to financial institutions apparently he
applied for loans
using the identifiers of a dead relative
this is dr terrance cash for you okay he
also apparently submitted fraudulent
documents to a bmw car dealership in
order to secure bmw vehicles for
associates of his he was imprisoned for
76 months before getting out and then
claiming that he's some successful
entrepreneur see he calls himself the
nation's number one business money
and wealth coach which is kind of
hilarious because he just got out of
prison
for financial fraud and he's trying to
teach you about money
remember that he has whole speeches
about how the difference between you and
the rich
is your relationship with money guys you
see the difference between
many of us and the rich affluent and
wealthy
is that the rich have a much more
enlightened and expansive mindset
oh yes guys he's got an enlightened and
expansive mindset of money see
once you get your enlightened mindset
you realize that scamming people is a
good way to make money
once you get enlightened like terence
chalk you realize hey maybe i'll just
forge some docs maybe get some cars with
dead relatives change my name then
create a chairman's fund
literally what's so insane about this is
that nearly everything
that was publicly available online
never would have suggested that
everything he said the diametrically
opposite thing was true for example he
said he sold his business for a ton of
money
but we find in the sec complaint that
that is not true
he was a convicted felon and his
previous businesses had suffered
financial difficulties
and until his arrest chuck repeatedly
attempted to prop them up
through fraud he calls himself a doctor
dr
cash but of course that is not true he
never received
a doctoral degree from any accredited
institution
now dr cash would deny that he would say
he got a doctor philosophy
from cica international university and
seminary
with a concentration in business
psychology there's only one problem with
that though i went to cica
and they don't offer any
degrees in business psychology they
offer a bachelor in theology masters in
theology
doctor philosophy and theology nothing
about business isn't that interesting
this stuff is completely insane so uh
yeah he claims to be successful he's not
successful he didn't have a successful
computer company it was floundering
um he claims to be a doctor he's not a
doctor uh he claims to be this retired
guy instead he went to prison
he claims to have this great mindset on
money but apparently yeah again
convicted for financial fraud and then
also he claims you're gonna make 12
percent
and instead he's not even investing most
of that money apparently
most of it was used to make a
combination of personal
and business expenses approximately 1.7
million dollars to pay bills
for personal credit cards which is just
for a guy who's preaching financial
literacy and you're spending a lot of
money
this is the guy who's always citing
financial imprudence
in all his lectures citing like how
basketball players have a bad mindset
with money how can you tell
it's because they're constantly spending
too much money and going broke after
making so much money that's just
evidence that people have a bad mindset
of money the average
nba basketball player makes about 6.4
million dollars per year over 70
of all nba basketball players will be
broken but you're the guy
who's spending 1.7 million dollars on
personal credit cards
so moral of the story don't trust
anybody
with the name of cash
uh doctor if you can't find where they
got their doctorate degree
don't trust anybody named million dollar
billion dollar trillion dollar man i
mean it's just
i don't know if this stuff is pretty
obvious but um it's worth
it's worth repeating guys stay safe out
there it's the era of covet the scammers
are running amok
and luckily some of them are going to be
going down and when they go down
coffeezilla will be here to celebrate to
celebrate
the conviction of just one more scammer
sweeping them off the street
one fraudster at a time thanks for
watching
and i'll see you guys next time and
don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
comes along